The sudden return of the population
provided the necessary energy
for the emergence to begin
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be how marvel's eternals movie is helping set
up the core x-men characters and mutants in the
mcu explain how they can just suddenly start
showing up in the next few years before the new
x-men solo movie that kevin feige has said that
they're working on and they'll be adults there's
a deep connection between the eternals the x-men
characters just in general that goes back to their
origin story and the eternals trailer references
some of those plot elements so we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos there'll be a
lot more eternals footage that'll start releasing
after the shangshi movie comes out during my big
eternals trailer videos and easter eggs that i
posted the last couple of days i explained how
some of the major conflicts of the eternals movie
are basically the hulk's infinity gauntlet snap
during avengers end game bringing everyone back
in the universe unleashes such a massive amount of
cosmic energy that it was enough to complete the
maturation process of this new celestial that's
growing inside planet earth the emergence that
they're referring to during the trailer footage
a new eternal emerging from its celestial cocoon
that's what this huge structure cersei is looking
at is in the trailer there's a scene that looks
like the meteorite crashing to earth when salma
hayek's ajak character is explaining this to
ikaris and they show you the origin of the mcu the
big bang all the other celestials being created by
eternity in the moments after the big bang that's
what this scene is the meteorite sounds like it's
the celestial egg so to speak crashing to earth to
begin its gestation process over millions of years
while that's happening it slowly absorbs
background cosmic radiation cosmic radiation like
the kind scarlet witch uses to power her chaos
magic the same type of energy the infinity stones
give up the same energy that was present at the
big bang when the other celestials were created
and this new celestial just grows and grows
until it eventually becomes larger like the
other members of the celestial host that we
see in the trailer like irishman the judge
in jamaica the analyzer they are massive
and super powerful so it just takes a long
long ass time for them to grow the only way to
accelerate that process is to just feed them
more background cosmic energy from the infinity
stones so this is where we get to our connection
between what's happening here mutants and the
core x-men characters mutants are a little bit
different in the mcu and in order to be considered
a mutant you need to be born with your powers and
typically you have to be able to express your
power generate your power from your own body in
some way your genetic code has to fundamentally
be different in some way than regular humans
they reference some of this during Wandavision
like monica rambeau's genetic code gets rewritten
basically mutates her dna by passing through the
hex so many different times there was a lot of
talk on Wandavision about whether or not billy
and tommy were the first true mutants in the mcu
or if scarlet witch and quicksilver qualified as
the first mutants because both of them were born
with their powers and the mind stone just unlocked
scarlet witch's full potential but she was already
born with her chaos magic abilities technically
that does qualify her as a mutant the only reason
why the mcu movies didn't acknowledge that earlier
was because of the legal rights issue with fox in
real life controlling the x-men characters and
marvel not being able to use the term mutant in
any of its movies until they bought fox in
2019 but regardless of that billy and tommy
are still both mutants in the mcu scarlet witch
used her chaos magic to create them to create
two new mutants and here's the connection
between what she did with chaos magic and
the celestial that's growing inside the cosmic
egg that we see during the eternals trailer
it's feeding on the same background cosmic
radiation the infinity stones from the snaps
in the same energy that wanda was using to power
her chaos magic when she was changing everything
inside the hex the same energy that was given off
by the big bang that eternity used to create the
original celestial host like airshim the judge
here the difference during the big bang though
is that there was so much of that energy present
that it was enough to create many celestials and
they're just way less of that energy at this point
in history when they're trying to mature this new
celestial then sort of bringing it back around
a Wandavision connecting this it's all connected
the producers of Wandavision said that in the
mcu the way they're explaining chaos magic that
it is magic of pure creation so when you talk
about mutants in the mcu the eternals movie is
kind of doing something similar to what wanda was
doing on Wandavision explaining how the growing
celestial absorbs all this cosmic radiation over
time but in turn while that's happening it also
gives off cosmic radiation like celestials are
super powerful even one that's growing it is
bursting with the same kind of cosmic
energy that the infinity stones give off
and while that's happening during human evolution
the cosmic radiation that the celestial is giving
off inside earth slowly starts mutating humans dna
to create the x gene they got into this idea in
the comics which is a slightly different explainer
it was celestial blood instead of just background
cosmic radiation so what they're doing during the
eternals movie is extremely similar to the comic
book explainer but fast forward to present day you
theoretically have many people all over the earth
randomly with the x gene but up to present day in
most cases the x gene has been dormant explaining
why you haven't seen reports of tons of teenagers
running around shooting lasers out of their eyes
this is also the same way that you can explain
older mutants like apocalypse or even wolverine
have been around this whole time because wolverine
was born in 1832 in the comics he's almost 170
years old during the events of the first x-men
movie this celestial's eternals explainer makes
it really easy to say that some of these mutants
powers did manifest across history like there
were actual mutants around but those individuals
either were able to stay off the radar or their
existence was kept secret by powerful people
in the mcu it's all a giant conspiracy they
even got into this idea recently in the comics
with a big x-men reboot professor x for instance
most powerful telepath on planet earth during that
storyline professor x learns that they're stuck in
a time loop like we talk about kang the multiverse
war he who remains in the time loop of the sacred
timeline professor x learns about this and learns
that mutants x-men are always destined to die out
to be killed off so he calls an audible and says
we're changing the game and he basically removes
memory of mutants from everyone's minds on planet
earth so that nobody knows they exist but in the
mcu at the end of the day the answer is still the
same mutants for instance have always been here we
just haven't known about them till now it's the
exact same explainer for the eternals characters
they've been here this whole time but this is why
we haven't known about them till now and it's all
because of what happened with avengers infinity
war avengers end game in the snaps is the same
thing they did in the early marvel phases after
the first avengers movie came out they used the
plot from avengers with the chitauri invasion and
how that affected earth as the basis for a lot of
the plot of the future movies like the reason why
iron man inadvertently winds up leading to the
creation of ultron was because of what happened
with the chitauri invasion anybody remember
when i carried a nuke through a wormhole no
it's never come up save new york never heard
that recall that so a lot of the big twists of
marvel phase four are built on the backs of all
these infinity gauntlet snaps that happened the
past couple of years in avengers infinity war
in avengers end game but all this cosmic energy
is unleashed activating people's x genes across
planet earth so that in the next couple of years
you start to hear more reports of people running
around with weird powers now that's just one
way that they'll probably explain mutants and
x-men in the mcu because the multiverse is such
a huge storytelling trope that they're leaning
into some of these new major characters will also
probably come from alternate universes which gets
into the events of loki the kang multiverse
war doctor strange two multiverse of madis
even spiderman no way home and even though it's
a little further off ant-man 3 quantum mania
all those movies will be the next step in
revealing mutants x-men characters and actually
we should also now add black panther to wakanda
forever to that list because of what they're
doing introducing namor and the atlanteans to the
mcu and he will have been here this whole time
but there is a cool connection between king the
conqueror who we just saw on loki and apocalypse
kang's first appearance in the comics was as
rama tut so in fantastic four number 19 he
travels back to ancient egypt sets himself up as
a pharaoh calls himself ramatud but eventually
once he gets bored with that decides to go to
a different time period he sets up apocalypse
as his successor that's also why they
included the great sphinx and the great
pyramid easter eggs during loki episode 5 just
as a reference to that part of kang's history
just in terms of that new x-men movie coming out
kevin feige has said that they haven't cast any
of the new core x-men characters like wolverine
yet but given all the movies that they've already
announced including deadpool 3 and avengers 5
which kevin feige just confirmed this past week
they've got so many movies coming out that they
wouldn't be able to release the new x-men movie
before 2024 so what's probably going to wind
up happening is that they'll just use the next
avengers movie avengers 5 as a sort of focal point
to set the stage for the new x-men solo movie like
both those movies will happen around the same time
and they'll be heavily connected but by that time
we'll probably have met at least a couple of the
core x-men characters in other people's big movies
i know there's all kinds of questions about legacy
actors coming back like will hugh jackman ever
come back as a version of old man logan wolverine
will patrick stewart ever come back most of them
are saying no like hugh jackman has even gone as
far to say that kevin feige has not contacted him
about coming back which i do not believe at all
i do believe that there's been some discussion
behind the scenes about finding a way to have
him cameo in some future project but when they
do get up to a new version of wolverine in the
mcu it will be a new actor like the new main
version of wolverine will be somebody different i
have a feeling they'll let ryan reynolds deadpool
character just joke a lot about that kind of stuff
when we get to the new deadpool movies in the mcu
so everyone let me know in the comments what kind
of easter eggs for mutants are you hoping to see
in the eternals movie i know everyone's hoping
for a galactus post-credit scene of some kind
since there are so many celestials and big cosmic
characters in that movie i'm not expecting a ton
of galactus easter eggs until they release their
new fantastic four movie which sounds like right
now is going to be released during 2023 at some
point we'll see that a long time before we see
the new x-men movie but there's a bunch of really
big stuff coming up in the next couple of weeks
i'll be doing some more shangshi videos once that
movie comes out my what if episode 3 video will
post on wednesday just like normal and there are
even rumors that a spiderman no way home trailer
might get released next week but i wouldn't hold
your breath on that one so if we get any kind
of spiderman footage of course i will do a whole
bunch of videos about it everyone click here for
my full eternals trailer breakdown in easter eggs
and click here for my other new eternals video and
footage thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you in the next video!